[Music]
the winner of the 2021 lux audience
award is
collective alexander nanau
[Applause]
for the first time european audiences
were able to vote for the winner along
with members of the european parliament
the story of collective starts in 2015
when a fire broke out in a bucharest
nightclub 27 young people died
and 180 were wounded but that was just
the beginning of the tragedy
burn victims continue to die in hospital
even though their wounds were not
life-threatening
i think this is an award most of all for
the victims and their families
for whom justice has still not been
served in romania
five years later there was no
compensation
nobody has yet been found guilty the
film follows a team of journalists whose
investigation
unravels a web of corruption in
romania's health system
that spread from hospitals to the very
top of the country's health ministry
this is also an award for the resilience
and the courage of normal citizens
that came out told the truth
and changed romanian society in 2016.
the film is a gripping expose of a
scandal that killed scores of people
and brought down the government because
we live in times of populism
we live in times when political parties
forget that they are there to serve
their citizens
and we live in times where truth
is more important than ever to
not lose our democratic societies
collective shows how a free press has
the power to expose the truth
demand justice and stand up for
[Music]
democracy
[Music]
you